let's now get to the other story from
the Alabama Georgia football game
involving Donald Trump I know this is a
weird thing to be talking about but the
video evidence is what's making me ask
this question does Donald Trump know the
words to the United States national
anthem does the patriotic 71 year old
American Donald Trump who has been
patriotically singing the national
anthem his whole life like any good
Republican would do does he know the
words
did he ever or has he forgotten them and
as I mentioned earlier Trump was at the
college football championship game last
night between Alabama and Georgia one
highlight from the game was actually
before the game when an Alabama player
possibly both scarborough yelled f trump
but another highlight took place before
the game during the singing of the
national anthem Trump went out on the
field flanked by military service
members of course and it appeared that
for long stretches of the national
anthem he didn't know the words he sort
of seemed to be wanting to sing along
I'm gonna play the video for you if
you're listening I'll describe to you
what it is that we're seeing and if
you're watching with me you'll see that
there are periods where Trump just
generally looks confused and stop
singing altogether kind of unsure what
to say let's take a look at a little bit
of this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you knew those couple words yeah that
was a good stop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's appearing for her
okay my question is alright in the
context of football
if kneeling during the national anthem
is disgrace or skirt graceful if being
off the field during the national anthem
is disrespectful
if protesting during the anthem in any
way makes you a son-of-a-bitch as Donald
Trump once said what is this now I want
to be clear Pat I don't actually think
this is that big of a deal I doubt I
could tell you the lyrics to the full
national anthem I might come close I
couldn't tell you the the the words to
the Argentinian national anthem I don't
think it's a big deal but in Trump's
world by his internal logic that he's
established respecting the anthem is of
paramount importance if Obama had done
this and seemed to flub the words it
would be 24/7 on right-wing media
foreigner non citizen Obama bungles
anthem lyrics but when it's Trump I
guess it doesn't matter anyway yeah so
then Trump doesn't have the grounds to
criticize others and there's no chance
that he knows what the star-spangled
banner is about - could he name the war
that the song was made for probably not
I think that's actually a more
interesting question which is for all
the people who hold the national anthem
in a sort of way the same sort of way
they hold the Constitution almost like
some kind of sacred text what's more
important knowing the words or actually
understanding the meaning and context in
which it was written I would argue the
latter but bottom line I don't think
that this is hugely important but it
does point to two items of interest
number one
Trump's ongoing hypocrisy when it comes
to what's okay for others to do versus
what it's okay for him to do and number
two when it comes to the cognitive
decline question did he know the words
to the national anthem at one point and
since has forgotten them which would not
exactly bolster the framework of a very
very stable genius maybe that part of
the song was outside of his vocal range
you know that could be yeah because I
he's a baritone right oh sure I have no
idea